mario tiene una pecera que es un prisma
rectangular con base de 15.6 centímetros
por 7.2 centímetros vamos a dibujar esta
pecera déjame poner por aquí el vidrio
frontal por ahí va a estar el vidrio
frontal de la pecera por aquí atrás está
el vidrio es el vidrio de atrás vale y
entonces voy a unir ahora estas esquinas
para construir mi pecera
voy a ponerlos algo así algo así algo
así está más o menos decente verdad ahí
tenemos un prisma rectangular que forma
la pecera y nos dice que la base es de
15 puntos 6 centímetros por 7.2
centímetros este de acá es 15 puntos 6
centímetros y el de acá es la medida de
este lado de 7.2 centímetros muy bien
luego nos dice que el fondo de la pecera
se llena con canicas voy a poner por ahí
algunas canicas no dice cuántas pero
bueno se llena con canicas y luego se
llena la pecera con agua a una altura de
6.4 centímetros muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos que vaciar agua a una altura de
6.4 yo me imagino que va a quedar más o
menos por acá más o menos por acá bueno
en realidad no nos dicen que tan alta es
la pecera entonces podemos suponer que
queda más o menos así estoy poniendo
esta agua en color como como morado es
agua un poco rara pero bueno lo que nos
dicen es que se llena se llena hasta que
la altura sea de 6.4 centímetros es esto
de acá verdad entonces esto de aquí es
66.4 centímetros y luego nos dice que
cuando se quitan las canicas la altura
del agua baja a 5.9 centímetros
entonces quitamos las canicas eso hace
que baje el volumen del agua y baja a
5.9 centímetros lo voy a poner más o
menos por acá
y aquí voy a unir estos dos estos dos y
estos dos entonces ahí está lo que
sucede lo que sucede cuando se quitan
las canicas esta altura es de 5.9
centímetros vale bueno a partir de esa
información queremos determinar cuál es
el volumen del agua desplazada por las
canicas eso básicamente es determinar el
volumen el volumen de la diferencia
verdad o más bien la la diferencia de
volúmenes de este cachito de acá de este
cachito de acá que también es otro
prisma rectangular que se forma vale
entonces vamos a determinar ese volumen
de ahí para eso primero tenemos que
encontrar cuál fue la diferencia de
alturas esta diferencia entre 6.4 y 5
puntos 9 centímetros
voy a ponerle aquí la diferencia
diferencia de alturas de d
alturas la diferencia de alturas es de
6.4 menos 5 punto 9 centímetros y eso de
ahí es igual a 0.5 entonces esta
diferencia de alturas desde 0.5
centímetros y por lo tanto se nos hace
otro prisma y aquí verdad esté acá es
otro prisma rectangular es más déjame
copiarlo de este lado para que lo veamos
mejor la tapa de atrás ahora va a ser
muy flaquita como algo de este estilo la
tapa de adelante es igualita pero un
poquito más para acá y esto queda unido
más o menos así más o menos así y más o
menos así espero que no se vea demasiado
raro y ahí está ahí está ya teníamos las
dimensiones por acá pero creo que es
mejor escribirlas de este lado entonces
justo ese es el prisma de la diferencia
de agua y ese prisma pues tiene base de
15 centímetros
necesito la herramienta de lápiz 15
centímetros 15 puntos 6 centímetros x 7
puntos 2 centímetros y acabamos de
calcular que su altura es de 0.5
centímetros 0.5 centímetros entonces
para ver cuál es el volumen del agua
desplazada por las canicas simplemente
hay que calcular el volumen de este
prisma y ese ya lo sabemos calcular para
calcular el volumen de un prisma
simplemente multiplicamos sus
dimensiones de esta forma el volumen
buscado lo voy a poner en otro color en
color naranja el volumen
volumen buscado es igual a 15 puntos 6
centímetros 15 puntos 6 centímetros por
7 puntos 2 centímetros 7 puntos 2
centímetros por 0.5 centímetros 0.5
centímetros vamos a empezar con esta
operación de acá porque está más fácil
multiplicar por 0.5 simplemente es sacar
la mitad verdad dividir entre 2 entonces
nos quedaría cambiando de color para que
no sea tan monótono que el volumen
el volumen es igual a 15.6 centímetros
por la mitad de 7.2 entonces sería por
por 3.6 y si quieres aquí le podemos
poner centímetros cuadrados nada más
notación al mente vale bueno aquí hay
que hacer 15.6 por 3.6 voy a hacer la
operación de este lado vamos a
olvidarnos por el momento de bueno voy a
poner los pues los puntos decimales 15.6
por 3.6 hago la multiplicación 6 por 6
336 llevamos 36 por 5 33 33 llevamos 36
por 16 y 39 vamos al siguiente renglón
aquí va un 0 3 por 6 18 y llevamos 13
por 5 este uno vaca verdad 3 por 5 es 15
y una que llevamos 16 llevamos 13 por 13
y una que llevamos 4 y aquí sumamos 6 0
6 3 y 8 11 llevamos 11 9 10
y 616 llevamos 156 56 16 y tenemos que
recorrer el punto decimal aquí se
recorre una vez aquí una vez entonces
aquí se recorre una y una dos veces
entonces nos queda finalmente que el
volumen
el volumen que estamos buscando es igual
a 56 punto 16 centímetros cúbicos